thank you for joining us America Sarah
is with us in Detroit hi Sarah how are
you hi Dave my question is about medical
school loans
I was wondering how if you deal with
those any differently my husband and I
are in our mid thirties we have a baby
and we're in our fifth year
post-training with four hundred and
fifty thousand dollars good lord what a
hot mess
no I wouldn't deal with it any
differently hopefully you've got an
income that's different
well we have one year left of training
and then we'll be getting our our whole
salary right 100 you make what you make
how much now about a hundred and we
should make 450 when we're done okay
well so let's kind of do a little math
okay you're living on a hundred now
right mm-hmm if when you're making 450
you lived on a hundred plus or minus
taxes you should have two hundred fifty
three hundred thousand dollars to work
with right okay so don't raise your
lifestyle and pay off that's in eighteen
months okay so would you avoid avoid
buying a house and pay for college
oh you're a hot mess you're broke we're
talking about 18 months two years I mean
you ought to be dead free in two years
wouldn't you agree with that yeah I'd
hope though yeah I would think I mean
you mean living on a hundred is not
exactly roughing it
no so I mean you depends on how much you
want to dial it down as to how fast you
get out but I can see you debt-free in
two years or less depending on how you
die how much you dial down the lifestyle
here's what you have to avoid Sarah I've
worked with Docs for years and I am so
happy that you're gonna be making
$450,000 a year you have earned it
already because you have done something
that the vast percent vast majority of
our population cannot do you have
delayed pleasure forever
you have been in school forever do you
have and for you in order
to do a greater good with your life for
your family and the help you can be as a
doc you have delayed pleasure beyond
belief right right the problem is I call
it doc itis doc itis is you've delayed
pleasure so long when you finally get
the big income you you'd like breathe
out and it sounds like two BMWs and a
boring or 50,000 hour house before you
clean up your mess right don't breathe
out you've been holding your breath for
16 17 years
hold it for two more years hold your
breath for two more years delay pleasure
delay pleasure one more time we know you
have the emotional capability of
delaying pleasure for a greater good
because your very life has indicated
that now apply that to the finances so
you don't look up 10 years from now
still paying student loan debts like all
the other broke freaking doctors out
there yeah broke doctors are about as
much of a stereotype as broke athletes
you know what I mean yeah
and it's because they're really really
smart at one thing and they don't use
common sense when it comes to money so
don't get doc itis just keep living like
a dadgum resident when you start getting
your good income and two years later
you're 100% debt-free now you're making
450 a year you got no chains around your
ankles no chains around your wrists no
chains around your neck and you can go
become wealthy very very quickly pay
cash for that gum house or pay it off in
three years after you buy it you can get
cars you can do whatever you want to do
on a $450,000 dadgum income and you've
earned it I'm glad you're making that
money I'm not one of those people who
didn't make two minutes mooning I do not
want broke I do not want a doctor that
is underpaid working on me thank you
very much
I want him paid very well I want her
paid very well and so I'm happy you're
there and I hope you make a lot of money
you have earned it and you guys work up
ridiculous hours and you're there for
people and you got the right hearts most
of you and I'm thrilled you're gonna
make a bunch of money please don't keep
these student loans around like their
pet knock them out fast that's my that's
my prescription so
doesn't change it's just the different
size a hole you're in and you got a
different size shovel but the principles
are still there thanks for calling in